si Monsieur ministre la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-Claude
mignon merci Monsieur Merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre des
Affaires étrangères lundi dernier le le
14 mars serait tenu se serait tenu une
réunion spéciale réunissant les chefs de
la diplomatie des pays membres de
l'Union européenne afin de tenter
d'arrêter une nouvelle stratégie
concernant les relations avec la Russie
alors je sais pas du tout si cette
information est réelle mais voudrait-il
ça voudrait dire que les capitales
européennes se seraient enfin rendu à la
conclusion et qu'il est grand temps
d'arrêter une nouvelle stratégie de
développer une coopération à long terme
avec la Russie et tout ça dans le cadre
d'un contexte nouveau si cette réunion
s'est tenue y a-t-il eu des décisions
concrètes qui ont été prises et par
ailleurs on nous annoncerait que
prochainement un rapport serait présent
d'opportunité un rapport d'opportunité
serait présenté aux ministres de l'Union
européenne afin de développer
éventuellement une coopération entre
l'Union européenne et l'union économique
eurasiatique donc est-ce que tout cela
est vrai si c'est vrai je m'en réjouis
je pense que nous pouvons nous en
réjouir a-t-il été aussi question de la
levée des sanctions contre la Russie
vous savez que le groupe les
républicains demande depuis très
longtemps qu'on puisse enfin lever les
sanctions contre la Russie et quelle est
votre position aujourd'hui quelle est la
position des autres pays de l'Union
Européenne j'ai cru comprendre que tout
le monde nétait pas d'accord l'Italie la
Hongrie entre autres sont sur une autre
position quelle est la position
aujourd'hui de l'Allemagne a-t-elle
évolué ou est-elle toujours aussi
dépendante de la position des États-Unis
je vous remercie de votre réponse merci
la parole est à Monsieur arlem désir
secrétaire d'État chargé des affaires
européennes merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député Jean-Claude mignon
vous m'interrogez sur la question des
sanctions européennes à l'égard de la
Russie et des relation entre l'Union
européenne et la Russie c'est un sujet
que vous connaissez bien en raison des
responsabilités que vous exercez que
vous avez exercé au Conseil de l'Europe
ces sanctions comme vous le savez ont
été décidées collectivement par les
États-membres de l'Union européenne en
raison d'une part de l'annexion de la
Crimée que nous ne reconnaissons pas
parce que c'est une violation du droit
international et d'autre part du conflit
dans l'est de l'Ukraine et du soutien
que la Russie apporte et a apporté aux
séparatistes russes ces sanctions
notamment les sanctions dites
sectorielles c'est-à-dire économiques
nous les avons aujourd'hui lié ensemble
les 28 étatsmembres de l'Union
européenne à la mise en œuvre des
engagements pris par la Russie et par
l'Ukraine dans le cadre des accords de
Minsk c'est-à-dire du format de
négociation Normandie qui est
aujourd'hui la feuille de route que sous
le parénage du président de la
République et de la la chancellière
allemande la communauté internationale a
mise en place pour permettre une
résolution de ce conflit permettre à
l'Ukraine de récupérer la souveraineté
sur la partie Est de son territoire d'y
organiser des élections et de rétablir
des relations normales entre la Russie
et l'Ukraine nous avons donc aujourd'hui
une situation qui est claire la balle
est dans le camp de la Russie il ne
tient qu'à elle de respecter ses
engagements de même que l'Ukraine doit
respecter les siens en particulier
l'adoption d'une réforme de la
Constitution et l'organisation
d'élections dans l'est de l'Ukraine et
notre objectif c'est bien
entendu PL s'il vous plaît allez
d'aboutir au respect de cette feuille de
route et à la levée de ces sanctions la
réunion à laquelle vous faites référence
est une réunion tout à fait officielle
c'est la réunion dite du Conseil
Affaires étrangères qui a eu lieu lundi
dernier à laquelle participait Jean-Marc
hraud et qui a évidemment traité de ce
sujet et de la résolution de la crise
entre l'Ukraine et la Russie